STEVE VINTER: Good to go?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
STEVE VINTER: Yes, it is.
All set?
Welcome, everybody.
It is my great pleasure to do
an introduction this morning.
My name is Steve Vinter.
I'm on of the site leads here.
A few years ago we had a
vision of creating a space that
was more than just a
way of connecting three
separate buildings, but was
actually creating a campus.
And one of the wonderful
outcomes of that
was the space that
we're sitting in today,
which we affectionately call
Boston Commons, which is just
an amazing place to meet
and to hear people talk.
And as part of the vision
of creating this space,
we also had the
vision of filling it
with big ideas and really
interesting people.
And it's my incredible pleasure
to introduce our speakers
today, who really are the
inaugural participants
in Thought Leadership
Series that we're
bringing into Cambridge,
and sharing with not just
Googlers in this building or
Googlers around the world,
but also with the
community here.
And the community
here is magnificent.
Obviously, we have
MIT across the street.
This university,
Harvard, I think
you may have heard of, up
the street a little bit.
But then, an amazing
mix of industries here.
Biotech.
The center of the world
is here, and so on.
So it's just a great
place to bring people in,
and I'm so happy that
we're starting here.
And what's really exciting
is about education,
which is one of my
personal passions.
So having the first session
talk about education is great.
I'd first like to
introduce Karen Miller.
She's the host and
executive director
of WGBH's Innovation
Hub radio show.
I don't know if you hear this
much, but from my perspective
WGBH is one of the jewels of
communication and information
in Boston.
KARA MILLER: Thank you.
STEVE VINTER: So you ought to
be very honored to work there.
Professor Eric Mazur.
He's from Harvard's
internationally recognized
Education Innovator,
and he's an advocate
of Peer Instruction,
which is what
we're going to talk about today.
A lot of people
would obviously think
that I would bring in
someone like Eric to talk.
But, obviously, I had a lot
of people to choose from
and I chose Eric simply because
it's his birthday today.
So let's hear it for
Eric's birthday today.
[APPLAUSE]
I think every birthday should
be spent coming to Google
and talking about
something you love.
And I think that's
the case today.
So thank you both for coming
here and joining the Thought
Leaders at Google Cambridge,
an event as you said,
is going to be streamed
everywhere through YouTube.
And welcome, all the people
who are out there in the world.
We do have a process that
we use called Dory, which
is a way of having live
questions be asked,
and we also have the system
for people to actually vote.
So the people that
are in this room
have little hand-held
things so you
get a chance to vote on things.
I have no idea how you're
going to use that, but use it
carefully and wisely
is my recommendation.
Without further
ado, Kara and Eric.
Thank you very much.
KARA MILLER: Thanks
so much, Steve.
Thanks to Warren,
and especially Carly
who really helped from the
beginning organize this.
And we talked about
in the beginning,
we wanted to bring
somebody who would
talk about an issue
that's of real interest
right now, that would
be fun here from,
and Eric was the first
person I thought of.
It is absolutely
right when Steve said,
there's a lot of biotech here.
There's a lot of really
interesting people and things
going on.
But Eric is a great
person to talk to.
So be thinking as we're
talking of your questions,
because we want to take those.
And if you're in the
room, there's the mics.
There's Dory.
If you're listening,
there's tweeting.
We're looking at your tweets.
So feel free to be part
of the conversation.
And as we said, as Steve alluded
to, there's a quiz coming up.
Literally, there's
a quiz coming up.
But let's just start with this.
And you've sort of
traveled this path
of learning about learning,
like what learning really means.
And I think we're at a point--
I mean, you teach at Harvard--
but we're at this point
of higher education
where, if you go
to private school
north of $200,000
a year-- I mean
$200,000 for the four years.
Getting to about a
quarter million dollars
to go to college.
And I think people
wonder, is it worth it?
Is it worth a tremendous
amount of paying back
student loans, a
tremendous amount of debt?
And you've seen how college
average-- what's your view?
ERIC MAZUR: Well, I think if
you look at the data they still
show that it's worth
paying that amount of money
for future returns.
The real question is, are
we using that money wisely
and educating people
in the optimal way?
And that is not
immediately obvious to me.
KARA MILLER: What are we
doing in those four years
that you see as potentially
not using the money wisely?
ERIC MAZUR: Well, I think
if you look at the approach
to teaching in most
classroom settings,
both in higher education and
also in K through 12 education,
it's a very antiquated
approach focusing mainly
on information transfer.
In fact, when I started
teaching at Harvard,
which is now, what,
over 30 years ago?
I never asked
myself the question,
how am I going to teach?
It was patently obvious
what I was going to do.
I was going to do
my students what
my professors had done to me.
And it's not because I wanted
to take revenge or anything.
It's basically because
I naively believed,
I learned it in a room not
very different from this one,
with everybody facing me and
the professors talking to me.
So that's how one learns.
So in a sense, I projected
my own experiences
and didn't really ask
myself, where did I learn it?
KARA MILLER: You were doing
the classic lecture, which
we've all been in
many, many times.
Were the students that
were learning from you
absorbing the material that
you were giving to them?
How much were they learning?
ERIC MAZUR: I don't know
if they were absorbing it.
Somebody once described
the lecture as a process
whereby the lecture
notes of the instructor
get transferred to the
notebooks of the students
without passing through
the brains of either.
That's pretty much what was
going on in my classroom.
Let me give you a
little bit more context.
I was asked to teach the class
that none of my colleagues
wanted to teach, physics
for pre-medical students.
These were not students who
wanted to learn physics.
They already dreaded
physics before setting foot
into my classroom.
At the end of the semester, the
evaluations of the instructor,
these pre-meds tended
to be very harsh.
This is why none
of my colleagues
wanted to teach that course.
And I, as an assistant
professor who
had not been educated
in this country,
didn't know any of this.
So I just accepted
this assignment.
Not that I had choice.
And what happened was
actually quite interesting.
The idea that I was
doing the right thing
got reinforced, because
the students ended up
high valuations.
Four point five on
a five-point scale.
They did well on the
examinations I gave them.
So I pretty quickly
became convinced
that I was the world's
best physics teacher.
KARA MILLER: And then?
ERIC MAZUR: And then.
KARA MILLER: I'm guessing
this doesn't end here,
in sweetness and
light and rainbows.
ERIC MAZUR: Well, it went
on for quite a few years.
I think seven or so.
And then in my seventh year,
just for getting tenure
at Harvard, I came across
an article that showed data,
basically that made an
instrument, a questionnaire,
if you want, using
word-based questions.
So no drawings, no equations.
Just words, to test
students' understanding
of very basic physics.
Essentially, the concept
of force, which you
learn in week one in
my course at Harvard.
And it showed that, in the
southwest of the US-- Arizona,
New Mexico, California--
if you test students
at the beginning of the term
and then you try it again
after two semesters,
there's no difference
between the pretest
at the beginning
and the post-test at the end.
And in both cases,
quite a few students
score even below
what a gorilla would
score by just
pressing random keys.
I thought, no way.
No way.
But I'm a scientist, so one
of things I've learned to do
is not just to make a statement.
I thought, I'm going to show
that my students at Harvard
do much better.
This was all in the
southwest of the US,
so I thought, maybe there's
some disease raging there.
Up here in the Northeast I'm
sure things are much better.
So it was too late
to do a pretest.
We were already two-thirds
into the semester.
So I gave it to my students.
It took no more than
one minute to tumble out
of my ivory tower,
because as soon
as they started looking
at the questions
on this questionnaire, one
student raise their hand.
I walked over to her
and she asked me,
Professor Mazur, how should
I answer these questions?
According to what you taught
us or according to the way
I usually think
about these things?
I had no idea how to answer
that question, and by the time
the test had been completed
I had been dragged out
of my ivory tower.
KARA MILLER: So now,
that seems to say
since an awful lot of
information transfer
goes on by professor is
lecturing to their students,
and if those students
aren't absorbing anything,
then what do we make of
what goes on in colleges?
I come back to you.
That's worth a quarter
million dollars?
ERIC MAZUR: Well clearly, I
think we still generate people
that end up doing better
than the people who
don't go to college.
KARA MILLER: But is
that just because they
have a piece of paper?
ERIC MAZUR: Well, I
like to say that you
take the types of
students that we
get in an institution
like mine-- Harvard,
or any other comparable
institution--
even if you were to put them in
a closet for four years they'd
come out smarter, right?
Because they're a
select group of students
that takes ownership
of their learning.
So you almost can't go wrong.
But I think what that little
anecdote that I just told you
about, which is true anecdote,
with that made me realize
is that, in the
classroom I had been
focusing on
information transfer.
I had basically been
transferring information
to the students as if the book
had not even been invented yet.
In a sense I was
transferring the information
from the textbook
to the students.
And education is, of course, so
much more, because as a learner
you need to make sense
of that information.
It's not enough
just to put it down
in your notes in your notebook
or try to remember it.
You have to do something
with that information.
You have to extract whatever
understanding, mental models,
interpretations there are that
you can apply in a new context.
Right?
Because we don't want to
train our students to only
be able to solve the
problems that we teach them
in the classroom.
Later on they'll take on
jobs that we don't even
have words for.
20 years ago the word "Google"
wouldn't have meant anything.
If somebody would have
come to me saying,
I need a web
programmer, I would have
had no idea what the
person was talking about.
So we need to prepare
students for the unknown.
And therefore, it's not
just the information.
It's sort of the mental models,
the skills, that underlie,
that transcendent, in a certain
sense, that information.
So I see education as
a two-step process.
One, information transfer.
Two, making sense
of that information.
And I ask myself
next, where did I
make sense of that information?
Where did I have the aha
moments, the, oh, I get it now.
Ask yourself that question.
I mean, you've been
in college classes.
You've sat there, right?
How many times did you go
"aha" in the classroom?
I think usually you go "aha"
outside of the classroom when
you struggle with
all the information
that you've taken down.
In part, that's because when
you're listening to somebody
speak, when you're
listening to a lecture,
there's no time to think.
Right?
I mean, if you think,
your mind wanders
and you're no longer listening.
Our brains are just not
wired for multitasking.
KARA MILLER: Joy Ito,
who some of you may know,
who runs the MIT
Media Lab-- he worked
with a lot of roboticists--
had somebody attach
a sensor to a student as
they went through their week,
and when their brain waves
were the least active
is when they were in class.
Less active than when
they were sleeping.
I mean, when they were
sleeping they were dreaming.
There's a certain amount
that goes on when you sleep,
but in class they
were really resting.
OK, so you learn this.
You learn that
the physics is not
being transferred, that people
don't really understand force.
What do you do?
How do you reshape your
classroom after that right?
ERIC MAZUR: So if
you see education
as a two-step process,
information transfer making
sense, and you
realize that educators
put most of their effort
on the first step,
leaving the second step to
the students on their own,
if you think about it
pragmatically it doesn't make
much more sense to have
students be responsible
for the information transfer.
And you, as the teacher
there, in order to help them
make sense of the information.
So basically, it boils down
to inverting this approach.
Flipping it, as it's called now.
So push the information transfer
outside of the classroom
so that you don't have to
regurgitate a textbook to them.
You can do that with
video or a book.
And then in class,
do something that
helps them build understanding.
KARA MILLER: So
I'm in your class.
I read the textbook
at home, and then
what do I do when
I get into class?
ERIC MAZUR: Well,
the answer to that--
that's a very good
question-- is, nothing new.
It's teach by questioning.
Socrates said that,
what, 2000 years ago.
Actually, I can explain to
you how I stumbled on this,
because the serendipity of
this is quite interesting.
See, after I'd given my students
this questionnaire that they
did so miserably
on, I was shocked.
They were shocked, too.
And they had the midterm
examination coming on,
so they wanted me to go
over every single question
before the exam.
So I came to a
question that dealt
with a truck and a car collide.
And I thought, in
my mind, it was
a completely trivial question.
So I made a few
drawings on the board
and in two minutes
I explained it.
And I turned around and I
could see from their faces
that they were confused.
So asked, is there
any questions?
They were so confused they
couldn't articulate a question.
So I thought, this is serious.
I erased the board, and
in the next eight minutes
I managed to produce the
most brilliant explanation
you can possibly imagine.
The whole board was covered
with equations and drawings,
and I triumphantly
turnaround, thinking,
I nailed it this
time, only to see
that they look
even more confused.
And they still couldn't
articulate a coherent question.
So you know how it is, right?
If you don't
understand something
it's hard to articulate it.
So I didn't know what to do.
I'd used my whole arsenal
trying to explain it.
But I knew that half of them
had given the right answer
on that particular question, so
in a moment of despair I said,
why don't you discuss
it with each other?
And something happened
that I'd never seen before.
I had 250 students in my class.
Complete chaos broke out.
They all started arguing.
They forgot about me
in front of the class.
I could've walked away.
They would not have noticed it.
And what happened is, two
minutes they figured it out.
At first I thought,
how is that possible?
Right?
I mean, I, the expert,
have taken 10 minutes
to explain it, unsuccessfully?
And in just two minutes
they figured it out?
Imagine you're Mary and John
sitting next to each other.
Mary has the right
answer, John does not.
On average, Mary's
more likely convince
John than the other way around.
But the key point is this.
Mary is more likely
to convince John
than Professor Mazur
in front of the class,
because she has only
recently learned it.
She still knows what
the difficulties
are to the beginning learner.
As Professor Mazur learned
it such a long time ago.
To him it is so clear that
he cannot even imagine why
somebody doesn't understand it.
KARA MILLER: So
you're going to do
a demo for us, of this sort of
idea of flipping the classroom.
So if you do not have one,
if you're in this room,
make sure you get one
of these, because you're
going to get to participate.
We're flipping the
classroom here.
And if you are watching
on the live stream, Eric,
you can tell people how
they can participate.
You can vote on what
the right answer is.
Take it away.
ERIC MAZUR: Well, first
of all it would be good
if you were not sitting
alone, because you will not
have anybody to talk to.
So you might want to
find somebody on Skype
to talk to, or sit
next to somebody.
But go to rwpoll.com-- RW,
ResponseWare-- and then
enter the session ID, emazur.
My initial, Eric, e, and then my
last name, M-A-Z-U-R. In fact,
if we could have the
slide up on the screen,
then you see my name and
the spelling on there.
And if you're a Twitter, you can
use my Twitter handle to tweet,
although I can't promise I'll
look at tweets while you talk.
OK, I asked you to give
them all this little handout
about thermal expansion.
Did you give that to them?
KARA MILLER: No.
ERIC MAZUR: You did not?
How are we going
to do this, then?
Because you need to read
to before coming to class.
Well, actually, it's great.
I'll give a little lecture
about thermal expansion.
I don't get to lecture
in my own classes,
so I'm actually
happy you didn't.
KARA MILLER: Fantastic.
ERIC MAZUR: So
thermal expansion is
something that is really
important in engineering.
Thermal expansion
deals with the fact
that hard solids, like wood
or steel or stone or concrete,
expand when they get hotter and
contract when they get colder.
For example, you may have
been in a train at low speed
and heard this clickety-clack
sound of the wheels
as the wheels go over gaps in
different sections of the rail.
You may have wondered,
why don't they
just jam the rails together?
Well, if they were not
leaving that little gap
between different sections
of the rail and the weather
heats up and the rail
expands, bad things
happen, as you can
see on the screen.
Same thing with steel-beam
buildings, like this one.
You need to take into
account the expansion
of the steel in hotter weather.
Otherwise, things can go
wrong with the expansion.
Next time you park your car in a
big concrete parking structure,
look down and you'll see that
the concrete doesn't extend
all the way from one side to
the other, but there are gaps.
Every 30 yards or so, there's
a gap filled with rubber
to permit the
concrete to expand.
Now, you may wonder
why materials expand.
Well, materials--
solids, I should
say-- are made, like
any other material,
from atoms that are
usually in fixed positions.
And atoms get further away from
each other when it gets hotter.
So this is cold, and that's hot.
Cold, and hot.
That's all there is to it.
That's the only thing
I'm going to test you on.
I won't test you on
it, but you my wonder,
why is it that they get
further away from each other?
The reason is that atoms
don't sit still, they vibrate.
And the amplitude
of that vibration
is what we call temperature.
So when you touch
something, in a sense
you feel the energy
associated with the atoms that
are moving back and forth.
If you are cold you
have little amplitude.
If you're hot, you
have a big amplitude,
which means you need more space.
And they all push
each other away.
Not just the nine that
are on the screen.
All of them.
The millions, billions of
atoms that make up a solid.
Cold, and hot.
Does anybody have any questions?
Thank you for reaffirming that
I'm such a great lecturer.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm not going to black
out the screen and ask you,
when solids get hotter,
they expand because A,
the atoms get further
away from each other.
Two, they stay
the same distance.
Three, they get close together.
That would be just me
giving information to you.
You giving that same
information back to me.
I want to see if you can take
this idea of the atoms getting
further away from each
other and apply it
in a different context.
So you better ask me questions.
Cold, and hot.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what happens
when something melts?
ERIC MAZUR: So what happens
Very good question.
Again, we only deal
with solids, so we
don't have to worry
about the question.
But as it gets
hotter and hotter,
the atoms go further and
further away from each other.
At a certain point they
lose their attraction
and they lose their
position, and they melt.
They go into a different
phase, and they eventually
become a gas.
But we won't get
anywhere near that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this
true for all solids?
ERIC MAZUR: Is true
for all solids.
Yes, absolutely.
Even ice.
Ice as it melts
does funny things,
but even if you take ice and
you cool it down, it shrinks.
And if you heat it
up again, it expands.
Until the melting point,
when strange things happen.
But yeah, it's true
for all solids.
All hard solids.
A bagel, or a fried egg.
It won't be, but any hard solid.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KARA MILLER: Do you
want to actually
come to the microphone,
then everybody can hear it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
So you've got this picture here
of the railroad tracks falling
apart.
Is that because the railroad
tracks got hot and the ground
didn't, or is that because there
are two different things going
on there?
ERIC MAZUR: No.
The track and the ground, of
course, both become hotter.
But the track as it expands,
each section of steel
becomes a little bit longer.
Right?
It becomes a little bit longer,
but it has no place to go,
because as it expands
and links, there's
another section
next to it, which
is also trying to get longer.
AUDIENCE: But didn't
the ground get longer?
ERIC MAZUR: Not as much.
That's a good question.
The stone does not
expand as much.
Actually, metals expand
much more than just
about any other material.
So thank you for
asking a question.
Excellent question.
I think you're ready, because
the questions you're asking
are way beyond what
I'm going to ask.
So get ready.
Oh by the way, let me quickly
show you how this works.
I see four of you.
I see this little window here.
I can see that already
four people have
been playing with
their clickers.
Very good.
Why don't you all
press a button?
And then you'll see that
this number here-- I
can zoom in-- so you
can see it goes up.
OK, very good.
The people who are remote,
there'll be a slight delay
but it'll go up.
And at any point, I can
display the distribution.
Why don't you all press one?
I love it when audiences
follow my instruction.
Thank you.
OK, and then when I hit stop
here you can no longer vote.
So this is what
we're going to do.
I'm going you ask
you a question.
You're going to think about
the question, about the answer.
It's going to be
multiple choice.
You press a button
that corresponds
to the answer you
think is correct.
If you change your mind
before I close the polling,
you can change your mind.
You can press, let's say,
first five and then seven.
The seven will
override the five.
Once I stop it you can
no longer change it.
I don't want you to
talk to anybody else.
I want your individual
commitment on that first round.
If I hear you talk
to somebody else,
I'll come to you
with this microphone
and you'll have to tell
everybody what you just
told him.
Then, I'm going
to ask you to find
a neighbor who has
a different answer.
So you turn to your neighbor
and you're right and you say,
I chose this answer.
If that neighbor
has the same answer,
you say, thank you
very much, and you
turn to the person on your left.
If everybody around you
has the same answer,
get up and walk around.
You have to find somebody
who has a different answer.
If you just sit there
without talking to anybody,
I will come and talk to you.
So find somebody
else and then try
to convince that person
that you are right
and he or she is wrong.
OK?
Clear?
Good.
So here is the question.
Consider a rectangular
metal plate
with a circular hole in it.
When the plate is
uniformly heated,
what happens to the
diameter of-- I haven't even
read the question and there's
already three people who
have answered-- what happens
to the diameter of the hole?
Does it increase?
Does it stay the same?
Or does it decrease?
I'm going to give you one
minute to think about it.
OK, so if you don't have the
answer right now, don't worry.
Nothing depends on it.
Your salary will
not be affected.
Nothing.
But just make it a game.
I do want you to make a choice.
So choose whichever you think is
the most reasonable answer, OK?
So we have a reasonable
number of responses,
so now please turn
to your neighbor.
Find a neighbor who
has a different answer,
and try to convince that
person of your answer.
And again, if you don't talk,
I'll come and talk to you.
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
ERIC MAZUR: Now look at this.
You all got engaged.
You got all fired up.
It's OK.
It's all right.
You're still talking.
They are gesticulating
about holes and so on.
Hello?
It's OK.
You probably have
all forgotten here
that Karen and I are
here not to teach you
about thermal expansion.
We're here to talk
about education.
The answer to this question
doesn't even matter.
You've already made my
point, how engaged you got.
Imagine I had just given my
little lecture, as I did,
and then instead of asking
you this question I said,
let's now apply this to
rectangular metal plates
with circular holes in it.
If you take one of these
plates and put it in an oven
and turn up the oven,
the plate expands
and the diameter
of the hole will--
I'm going to keep you in
suspense a little bit longer.
You would have not
been engaged like this.
You would have been
sleeping through this.
I mean, what is more boring
than rectangular metal plates
with circular hols in it?
Isn't it amazing
how you can turn
on the curiosity
of the human mind?
Right?
We're all born curious and
inquisitive, and asking
for why and reasons
and everything.
If anything,
education does really
a good job turning that
curiosity off, right?
It's only later in life
that we rediscover it.
In a sense, what
I've shown you here
is how easy it is to
reignite that curiosity,
a curiosity that gives you
ownership of you're learning.
Now, I know you want the answer.
But before I tell you
what the answer is,
let's analyze what happened.
I asked you a question, and then
I had you make a commitment.
You had to choose an
answer and press a button.
And after you made
that commitment
I asked you to turn
to your neighbor
and to externalize your answer.
I chose.
And something interesting
happened there,
because in that explanation--
even though I didn't come down
from the podium
and listen to you,
I could see it from
your gesticulation--
you moved away from the
answer to the reasoning.
It was no longer
about the answer,
it was about how you
get to the answer.
So much education is focused
on the outcome and the answer,
and students are
evaluated on the answers.
But in any real world
problem, the outcome is known.
It's the path to the
outcome that's unknown.
It's a thinking skill.
This brings the thinking
back in the classroom.
But most importantly, you
became emotionally invested
in the learning process.
If Kara were to shut
me down and say,
Eric, we have only a few
minutes left for questions,
and then we left,
you'd come running
after me asking
what the answer is.
You want to know the answer,
even though we're not here
to talk about thermal expansion.
We're here to talk
about pedagogy.
OK, so before I can
give you the answer--
KARA MILLER: I have
to say, when you
said, OK, stop talking,
let's talk about why
you got all fired up, somebody
out there screamed at you,
what's the answer?
So talk about fired up.
ERIC MAZUR: Before I
can tell you the answer
you need to vote a second time.
We need a first vote
and a second vote.
So please, vote again,
indicating what you now
believe to be the
correct answer.
If you've chosen
a certain answer
and you've not
changed your mind,
then you just vote
the same thing again.
But you have to
vote a second time.
And I'm going to give
you 10 more seconds here.
And there's a slight delay for
people online, but that's OK.
I have bad news for you.
I thought I gave a pretty clear
lecture on thermal expansion,
and so did you.
You had only 33% got
the right answer,
which means one in three.
You should really
have done your reading
before coming to this show.
Anyway, in a sense
you've helped me
make a really important point,
because you've been telling me,
Eric, you're lecturing sucks.
After all, you got
only 33% right.
But the method doesn't
work that well when
there's only 33% right,
because it means only one
person of every three people.
Typically you want to
have a higher percentage.
Anyway, the right
answer is-- oh,
look at all the attention
I'm getting here.
There's not a single person
looking at his or her computer
screen or texting or tweeting.
All right, so the right
answer-- I need a new drum
roll-- the right
answer is, number one.
Let's see what the
second vote was.
A small miracle happened,
because look at this.
This was the initial
distribution here, 33%.
So the correct answer
went up, that one-third
had had the right answer
effectively convinced
the other.
But there were just
not enough of it.
So typically want to
choose your questions--
I chose this
question on purpose,
because I knew people would
score around this level--
so that about half of
the people get it right.
Then you find the largest
short-term learning gains.
Now, I don't want you to lie
in bed tonight at 2 AM awake,
thinking, why is this
hole getting larger?
Can I take another minute
of my precious time here?
KARA MILLER: Yeah, go ahead.
ERIC MAZUR: OK.
Take a jar of jam that's
in the refrigerator.
Glass jar, metal lid.
Take it out of the refrigerator.
You can't open it.
What do you do?
You run the lid under hot water.
The lid is a ring and a plate,
and the ring gets bigger,
so the hole in the
ring gets bigger.
You knew this already.
You say, well, you asked about
a plate, not about a jar.
OK.
I'm going to steal
your little piece here.
KARA MILLER: Yeah, that's fine.
ERIC MAZUR: Imagine
that we have a plate.
No hole.
Here's the plate.
We draw a circle
on it, so now we
have a plate with
a circle on it.
We put it in the oven.
Turn up the temperature,
the plate expands.
What happens to the
diameter of the hole?
Gets larger.
Everything gets larger, so
that has to get larger, too.
You said, that's unfair.
You asked about a metal
plate with a hole,
and if there's a
hole then the atoms
are going to expand
into the hole.
In fact, most of
you had that answer.
Let me show you what's
wrong with that.
Imagine we go outside and we
form a circle holding hands.
We are the atoms at
the edge of the hole.
Now we step in towards
the center of the whole.
What just happened to
the distance between us?
It gets smaller.
We get crunched together.
It can't do it, because
we need more space.
We're shaking more.
The only way to increase the
distance is to take a few of us
away.
But atoms don't
disappear like that.
Or, to make the whole larger.
You won't forget this.
KARA MILLER: OK, so how do
you take that kind of response
and that kind of
engagement and replicate it
across more college classes?
Because I did not have
any college classes
where anybody brought
anything this into it.
I had college
classes where people
read chapters of their books.
Like chapter eight
today, because this
is the eighth week of the class.
So how do you change things?
Is that possible to do?
Are teachers too
resistant to that?
ERIC MAZUR: Change
is very difficult,
for a large number of reasons.
The first one is, most
teachers are perfectly
happy with what they're doing.
There's no indication that
there's anything wrong, really,
and change is
threatening, because you
don't know what it's going
to do to your end of semester
evaluation.
You don't know how it's
going to affect you.
So unless there's a real
reason to change, why change?
So that's one problem.
The second thing is that the
students also demand lecturing.
By the time to get into
college they've already
been pre-conditioned
to think, the professor
should be lecturing me.
In fact, I have
some students who--
after I switched to this
interactive teaching, which
has been 24 years
ago now-- write
at the end of their
evaluation questionnaire,
Professor Mazur is not
teaching us anything.
We have to learn
it all ourselves.
So I think there's resistance
from the students, too.
And, of course, higher
education depends on K
through 12 education.
K through 12 education
depends on higher education.
So it's all sort of an
interlocking mechanism that
prevents change,
in a certain sense.
KARA MILLER: I want to get your
questions in about two minutes,
so be thinking of them.
So K through 12 education.
I know you travel
all over the place.
When we were trying to schedule
a day that you could come here,
talking to Eric on the
phone is mind-blowing.
He's like, well, I'm going
to be in Birmingham, Alabama,
and then I'm going to
be in the Netherlands,
and then I'm going
to be in Africa.
I mean, it's crazy.
And almost
everybody's having you
come and talk about
education and how
you've change education.
So where are you
seeing the interest
for people who actually-- I
mean, somebody's inviting you
to speak, so somebody must be
interested in changing things.
ERIC MAZUR: Yeah.
Amazingly, I'm seeing
it from everywhere.
And I think in part it
is because of-- I'm not
a big believer in MOOCs.
MOOCs or any online type
of learning environment
basically replicate a
failed model online,
and they basically focus, again,
on this information transfer,
not on the engagement.
But what the MOOC
has done is it made
faculty realize that whatever
they do in the classroom
can be put online.
And then they lose
their job, so they
start questioning
about the value of what
is happening in their classroom.
And the whole flipped
class movement,
which is focused mostly on
the out-of-class component,
is now all of sudden
thinking, what
is it that we're going
to do in the classroom
if students are getting ready?
So maybe those are things
that are slowly driving people
to realize that we
shouldn't basically
be doing what people
did in the Middle Ages.
Other than maybe wearing
our robes at graduation.
Let's keep that tradition.
KARA MILLER: So let me
open this up to questions.
There are these two
microphones here,
and then if we get anything from
Dory or Twitter, let me know.
There's one right
here, and if you
want to just get in line
and I'll call on you.
AUDIENCE: I've been a fan of
what you've done for a couple
years, and I've followed
that exact problem
and asked it to at
least 200 people.
And PhDs in sciences
generally get it wrong.
Car mechanics, plumbers,
emergency medical technicians
generally get it right.
So my question is, do we
have things really wrong
in a profound way?
Do we have people who are
really great at hands-on,
intuitive learning that could
be high-quality experimental
physicists, but
because they're not
good at fast manipulation
of algebraic expressions
on standardized tests-- and I'm
a big fan of a car mechanic--
but are we limiting the
careers because we're
teaching the wrong things
and measuring the wrong way?
ERIC MAZUR: That's a
very good question,
and I think one of the
problems is that, of course,
a lot of education is
focused on content.
But to me, in a
certain sense, content
is irrelevant,
because we don't know
what our students will
need later in life.
It's the skills, really,
that matter, right?
In the traditional approach to
teaching you start by thinking,
what am I going to
cover in this course?
Topic one, topic two,
topic three, topic four.
Then you start covering
in the classroom and then
after a month or so
you ask yourself,
hmm, how am I going to
assess whether or not
my students have learned it?
And you set an examination,
and then usually you're
disappointed that you
haven't accomplished
what you wanted to.
A much more logical
approach would
be to use backward design, to
start at the output, advocated
by Grant Wiggins and Jay
McTighe in their book,
"Understanding by Design."
So why not ask ourselves,
what are the desired
outcomes of this
educational discourse?
And you have to formulate
those with action verbs
rather than saying, content
topic one, topic two, topic
three.
You have to ask
yourself, what do
I want my student to be able
to do after taking this course,
or after finishing this year
in school or in college?
A lot of my colleagues
really like that,
but they have a lot of
difficulty with that.
They will say, well,
after taking this course,
you will be able to understand
Topic A, Topic B, Topic
C. The content is so ingrained.
Anyway, once you have
formulated outcomes,
you can ask yourself, what am
I going to accept as evidence?
So you think about
the assessment.
And then, what am I going
to do in the classroom
to maximize those outcomes?
And I think in education we
haven't done enough of that.
KARA MILLER: I've
heard engineers say--
and engineering is an area
where there's a ton of dropout.
People start and
they're thinking,
oh, I'm going to be a
mechanical engineer,
and there's a lot of
people along the way
before they get to be a senior
in college drop that major.
And I've heard people
say it's because it's not
until your senior that
you build anything.
People say, you have
to take these courses
in physics and calculus.
And I know you want
to build things,
but you can't build
anything for several years.
The thing is out there
at the end, the prize,
but it's a very long
time before you actually
get to do the fun stuff.
Question here.
AUDIENCE: I was one
of the people who
changed our answers on the basis
of talking to somebody else,
and it was interesting to
me because it wasn't exactly
that I agreed with the
other person's explanation
or theory of what was going on.
It was more that it
caused me to realize
that, in my original thinking,
it was exactly what you ended
up with in your explanation,
that the only way
for the circle to get smaller
would be for some atoms
to be closer together,
which would violate
the whole principle.
But that was not the explanation
that the other person gave it
all.
So what's interesting
to me about it
is what was going on there.
And so, for example, you offered
earlier one sort of suggestion
that there's something
about emotional investment.
So one theory, one
hypothesis, might
be, you get emotionally
invested and that
makes you more motivated
to question and dive
deeper into your own thought
patterns or whatever.
I'm sure there are many other
hypotheses for what's going on,
and I'm sure that by this
point many people have studied
the psychological and
cognitive aspects of what's
really happening here.
And I wonder if you could just
say a few words about what
the current thinking is on that.
ERIC MAZUR: Yeah.
Of course, it's not
that easy to study,
because you can't measure what's
going on in people's head.
But we've done an
experiment where
we vary the activity
between the two polling.
So what you did was
poll, discuss, repoll.
So what we've done with a
class is we've taken students,
we've polled them, then
distracted them with cartoons.
No talking, were just
distracted with cartoons,
and we polled them again.
And then we took another set
of students and we polled them,
and then we were silent
for two minutes so
that they don't exchange
ideas and they don't talk.
And we polled them again.
And then poll, discuss.
So depending on the
activity in the middle
we find some
interesting results.
Even if you distract
people with cartoons,
the second polling, on
average, is 4% higher
than the one before.
So clearly, even though
you distract them,
people keep thinking.
If you don't distract them
and you give them all the time
to really continue to think,
you see a much larger gain,
like 10%.
But that shoots up to 16%
once you have the discussion.
So the discussion
actually does something.
The interchange of ideas.
And had I showed you some
video of my classroom--
I didn't pay enough attention
to you while you were talking--
but if you see a
video of my classroom,
you'll actually see
students go, oh.
You see that aha moment
occurring in front of you.
So clearly, at some
point in the discussion,
triggered by who knows what,
you had this aha moment.
Aha moment was, if the
circle gets smaller,
the atoms are crunched together.
What exactly triggered that?
I don't know.
That's one of the
mysteries of the brain.
Because learning, after all,
is a social experience, right?
In fact, most of the
things we do-- everything
we de-- is a social
experiment, learning included.
Even though we treat it
like a completely individual
experience, which I think is
not the right thing to do.
KARA MILLER: Another
question here.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to read a
few questions from the Dory.
What kinds of technological
advancements-- hardware
or software-- would
help peer instruction
become even more effective?
What sort of not-yet-developed
gizmo or application
do you think would be useful?
ERIC MAZUR: OK, so when I
started there was no hardware.
It just got developed as a
result of peer instruction,
and it's now a $100
million-a-year industry,
growing.
But it's not about
the technology.
It's about the pedagogy.
We could have done
exactly the same thing
with hands on the chest
indicating one, two, three,
or having flashcards, and
I would have seen the same.
There would have
been same engagement.
It's not about the technology.
It's about the pedagogy.
Now, after this I founded
a software company,
Learning Catalytics,
that basically
allows people to use handheld
devices like smartphones
or laptops.
And also, get away
from multiple choice.
So people can just
draw something,
or they can type in
an expression or type
in some words, and the
system can actually
analyze, use analytics, hence
the word "learning catalytics,"
to basically
tabulate the answers
and display them in a meaningful
way for the instructor.
Where do we go from here?
I think the big interesting
thing is, how do we push this
from a synchronous mode,
which is what we did here,
to something that's asynchronous
and on the internet as a whole?
Frankly, that's not
completely clear to me.
But that's an interesting
question to study.
KARA MILLER: It's interesting.
A lot of you know Sal Kahn.
Obviously, Khan Academy is big.
And when you kind
of press him on,
how do you really
make this interactive?
He says, kids do
do modules at home.
They come in.
The teacher basically has a
screen and can look and see,
well, Johnny does
not understand when
you've got two equations
with two different variables.
He's not getting that.
And they can go over.
But then, how do you take
the teacher out of that?
The final thing is, can
you take the teacher out
of that equation and
still make it work?
And I think you're saying
it's kind of not clear
yet that you can, that
it can all be online.
ERIC MAZUR: That's the question.
Could you move some
of that online?
Actually you can teach take
the teacher out of this.
There's an organization in India
called the Monte Fellows that
took this idea of
peer instruction
and did something
absolutely amazing.
Mind-blowing.
India has a big shortage
of science teachers,
especially in rural India.
And they have a
need for, I think,
several million
science teachers.
No way they can
even generate that.
So what they did is, they
created this organization
that develops a curriculum,
which is interactive,
and then they have
classroos staffed
by social workers who
have no content knowledge.
None whatsoever.
I went to see one of these
classrooms in Mumbai.
You have to imagine 40
kids crammed together
in a space not much larger than
this stage with just two of us
on it right now.
Shoulder to shoulder.
And the social
worker shows a video
of an instructor delivering
some science class.
Five, seven minutes.
And then comes up a
question, just like you did.
They raised colored cards
depending on the answer
that they choose.
The instructor quickly counts
them and said, now turn to you
neighbor.
She has no idea what
the question is.
She knows from her script
what the right answer is,
but she would not be
able to explain it.
Kids start talking.
You see this chaos, and then
they raise their flashcards
again and you see an
overwhelming shift
to the correct answer.
And then she said--
and I was really
wondering, how is she going
to handle this-- she says,
are there any remaining-- oh no.
First she shows an explanation.
It would be the instructor
in New Delhi giving
the explanation.
And then the social
worker in the classroom
said, does anybody have
any remaining questions?
I thought, how is
she going to answer
that given that she
doesn't know any physics?
One student raises
his hand and says,
well I don't understand why
blah, blah, blah and so on.
So she says, is there anybody
who knows the answer to that?
She just plays the kids
out against one another.
And if there's an issue
that remains unresolved
she takes it down.
It gets sent to the mother
office, the main office in New
Delhi, and they resolve
it the next time around.
Fantastic.
I always thought
that the teacher
had to be here if
the kids were there.
But the balance is the
other way around there.
Watch the YouTube video
about [INAUDIBLE] Fellows
on the internet.
It's really very encouraging.
KARA MILLER: So we're
running low on time,
so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take all three
of your questions and then
we'll tackle them as a group,
if that works.
If they all make sense together.
We'll make them
make sense together.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
You referred to
teachers figuring out
how to evaluate students and
teachers being evaluated.
Of course, in Massachusetts
we have the much-loved MCAS.
How do you see in this
process the better way
of evaluating
students and teachers?
KARA MILLER: OK,
testing and evaluation.
AUDIENCE: This does kind
of follow along there,
and that is, how
does this change
the nature of the
take-home work.
Are you completely replacing
the take-home problem
set with the
lecture or the book,
or is there still a place
for, I'm on my own in my room,
thinking, struggling
through this myself.
AUDIENCE 2: So
I've recently read
a book called "Talent
is Overrated,"
by Geoff Colvin, that gives
a popular summary of research
on delivered practice,
the thesis of which
is that the extent to which a
person acquires a specialized
skill is determined, basically,
by the amount of repeated
practice they do of
tasks that are just
beyond their current ability
in which they receive feedback
about how they
missed perfection.
That is, what needs
improvement next.
And I'm curious what
intersection your methods
that you're proposing
have with this idea.
ERIC MAZUR: OK, first
this last question,
because it was not as much
related to the others.
I think it was Dan Pink who once
said that the single strongest
indicator of success is
persistence and perseverance.
I think it was he
who once said that.
And I think that's so true.
If you stick to it,
if you push yourself.
Take the light bulb.
Thomas Edison.
He didn't just
invent a light bulb.
There were 300 failures
before he finally got there.
But he persisted and
continued and continued.
Failure is so essential
and we don't teach failure.
Failure means you
take points off.
And that brings
me to assessment,
which I'm very
happy this comes up.
I wish we had another
hour to talk about.
But assessment is actually
the other part of education.
And I realized two years
ago, all of sudden,
that the students
in my class were not
really learning to learn.
They were learning to
pass the assessment.
And, of course,
in an ideal world
those two things are the same.
But the there are many shortcuts
to passing the assessment.
It's not really learning.
And that made me aware of the
fact that I really had to start
radically changing
the assessment.
Unfortunately, I think
we're almost out of time.
But I have a YouTube video
called "Assessment-- The Silent
Killer of Learning."
Kind of a negative title,
but I truly believe.
I spent all these years
thinking about the input.
What do you do in the classroom?
Not really thinking
about how the assessment
is what drives the
students' study habits.
So we need to spend as much time
rethinking the assessment as we
are rethinking the
approach teaching.
Much less work has
been done there,
but there are some
promising approaches.
KARA MILLER: Let me just
insert one second, which is you
and I were once talking
and you told me the story.
Tell me if anything's
wrong here.
But the people who got
into your physics class
at Harvard who had
taken AP Physics
were no better than the people
who hadn't taken AP Physics.
And you were wondering
what was wrong
the AP test, so you tried
to change the AP test.
And they told you your
questions weren't good,
because high school
physics students couldn't
do those questions.
ERIC MAZUR: Right.
Well, actually, they
said, our good students
don't do well on your questions.
Because the good students
did well on questions
that are actually
quite meaningless.
For five years I tried to change
the AP Physics B and C exam,
only to realize that
ETS and the whole AP
and standardized
testing enterprise
is like a supertanker, which
is already hard to maneuver,
where you've removed the rudder.
There's only one way it can go.
Straight.
So it's unfortunate
that we have MCAS.
Somebody here was talking about
MCAS and standardized testing,
because it's only as good
as what type of skills
that test really tests.
And unfortunately, if you look
at the thinking skills that
are tested by many
standardized instruments,
they're not very high.
A lot of them are remembering
and understanding, rather than
being able to apply or analysis,
or any type of creative skill.
KARA MILLER: And let's
touch on that last question.
So is this the end
of the problem set?
Is what happens that you go
home and you either read a book
or you watch a
video by yourself,
and then you come into class
and have a remote control
and talk about--
ERIC MAZUR: No, no, no, no.
No, of course that's not enough.
The homework consists not
only about watching a lecture
or reading a book but
also applying some.
Learning is a
scaffolded process.
You don't go from
not knowing anything
to knowing everything
in one step.
You learn a little bit,
and a little bit more.
So the reading primes
the pump, or the watching
the lecture primes the pump.
The in-class activity pushes the
students a little bit higher,
and then there are other
activities, some of which
can be done at
home, that continue
to reinforce the process.
It's really a
scaffolded process.
KARA MILLER: Eric Mazur,
thank you so much.
I feel like this hour
went by so quickly.
Thank you for all
your questions.
Thanks.
That was great.
ERIC MAZUR : Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]